sketch someone anyway maybe they're
funny spatially is not that guy
no he's not oh it would probably sell
more tickets probably yeah see that's
where tied in from like the core beer
Pro just like super calm and respectful
oh yeah it's hard to believe he was just
in a cage fight yeah
dude he shuttles out dere until hype up
quick I knew he's gonna win I would like
to talk to her own or do can see if
sorry to interrupt and because how he
caught him because Derek - I made a
video about this how dare until
typically likes to faint and pump and
get the guy backing up get them out of
position and then land the cross you
know from open stance from southpaw and
there is a slight delay between those 2
to 3 punches that he throws and I'm
wondering if Tyrone did is researched
and seen happen Tyron is he say Tyron
not Tyrone
mr. Woodleigh right Tyron will tire in
Paris a tyrant there's no not now the
joke wouldn't mean that's funny that's
not wondering if you can read that from
watching the videos previously and seen
that little gap in this combination was
able to beat him to the punch
or if he just duck and chucked I'm
curious to see if that was a something
if they trained inside out or because
that takes balls right these come in
with his strongest punches cross that
he's knocked many people out with and he
just stepped into it and beat him to the
punch that takes balls
Tyron that's his he always does that
strategy of standing against the fence
or closer to the fence and then when
guys move any counters yes I mean he did
that with Josh Koscheck he's done that
with a lot of guys and Rory MacDonald
was the only guy to shut that down he
figured out the way to shut it down he
stayed long stayed long he's a lot of
front kicks a lot of jabs keep kept his
left hand up high to block the right
hand you know the big right hand but man
your time was just faster than him wait
that in yeah
like lightning landed that right hand
beat the [ __ ] out of him on the ground
it was just shocking to me that Darren
didn't know what to do
when he was on his back like in terms of
like that's right that's how I thought
if I was gonna go like him just be on
top in the whole thing I thought Terrans
just gonna be on top well I thought
maybe that was part of the strategy too
especially when you saw them warming up
because Terran was doing like a lot of
like exchanges and then shoots for a
double or closes the distance level
changes like they did that when
was working with boxing coaches as well
he would hit the hit the mitts and then
move in level to blend it together but I
was just like till didn't understand the
darks was coming or didn't know but then
you got to wonder how battered was he
took that big shot took a lot of hard
elbows in the ground how much was he
really there yeah that's a beauty I'm
sorry no I was gonna say because that
Darce was left mile away I mean it was
there and then it was there and then he
cinched it up deep it was never like
there was never any separation never
pulling the hands back to think Terrans
a lot stronger than him to able to hold
him in that crunch he's a freak yeah
he's abusing why is the champion but I
think that's the well the way I choose
to look at anyway is having a checklist
right if you were to build up a mixed
martial artist how much information
should they know standing wrestling and
then on the ground and they should just
check check check and know all these
basics should be covered before you go
fight yeah there's a beauty beauty of
having a curriculum and again a
checklist no I absolutely agree with you
I think you know understand I mean the
days of just like being able to just
fight someone and not know anything
about them that seems kind of foolish
you know it seems like a massive
advantage to study like when cowboy
fought Dare until he decided to not
watch any tape on him he's like you know
here's the Stryker good I love to strike
okay might want to watch this Stryker
yeah yeah